thank you
well welcome back for some of you
welcome for some of you this talk came
about because about two years ago made a
proposal to present at a conference on
this topic in 40 minutes and I realized
as I got closer to the topic to the time
of the conference there was a rising
sense of panic because no no it's been a
few hours talking about this topic as
part of a course and then I asked can I
actually do this in 40 minutes and I
began to fear it was not possible
two things save me one is a picture that
I invented which I think really helps to
bring things together the other was that
the conference was oversubscribed and
people couldn't get into the rooms if
they came in late so they were all
arriving early and I started my talking
started my talk five minutes early I can
do it in 45 minutes so having you know
you know possibly the squeeze into an
hour here and having already done some
stuff in the previous session like this
is this is relaxed okay
so I've got some slides in here that I
represented in the previous presentation
I'm going to go through those this is
the slides there because sometimes I do
just this presentation as a standalone
presentation so there's a couple of
pieces in there and they're there in the
middle understand skip over oh I I am
still me okay same me that was here an
hour ago
I'm still the main pages maintainer I
still wrote a book I still teach courses
there's some course books now as I said
I normally spend a lot of time on this
so even though I have more time than
usual and in a you know in a conference
context I still AM you know reasonably
fast as a there's some details I'm going
to leave out but I hope that you'll walk
away with a picture of what user name
spaces why they are kind of magical okay
but first I need a little bit of
background and this is the notion of
capabilities on Linux now
traditionally on UNIX systems the
privilege model is is is quite a simple
one there's two categories of users
there's normal users who are subject to
a lot of checks on what they are allowed
to do a lot of restrictions and the
super user user ID zero who can bypass
many of these restrictions and then this
sort of prove this sort of very coarse
privilege model is is is is it's
problematic because I know long so I've
jumped I've jumped up a second jump to
jump forward a second and of course the
way traditionally to give an
unprivileged user the possibility to do
something privileged is to allow them to
use a set UID root program create a set
UID root program that does some
privileged operation and then when the
user executes that program the resulting
process has UID 0 and it has the powers
of super user and this is a useful
technique it's a powerful technique but
it's also a dangerous technique and the
problem is that problem Springs out of
this coarse granularity of this
privilege model because maybe we're
going to write a set UID program that
hypothetically speaking let's the number
of user changed the system time now you
know only super user can do that so we
create a sent UID root program that lets
unprinted uses change the system time
but if that program could somehow be
compromised by an attacker then that
program the compromised program could
potentially do any kind of dangerous
thing that super user could do on the
system and this is my set UID root
program that are dangerous because if
they're compromised you have all the
power of super user so when these
programs are compromised there's no
limit to the damage that can be done you
know if the attacker can can gain full
control of the program capabilities are
an attempt
- to sort of solve this problem and the
idea of capabilities is let's divide the
power of superuser into small pieces and
currently there are 38 of these small
pieces you can see them described and
the capabilities manual page for example
these are some of the capabilities cap
DAC override this is a process for this
capability can bypass file machine
checks read and write any file on the
system go through any directory caps
this time that's the capabilities to
change the system time capsule sad Minh
is a kind of sad capability because it
lets you do way too much but that's
that's that's a rant for another day the
point is now you could instead of having
set UID root programs which are so
powerful and very dangerous that they
compromised now you can have programs
that have just one of these 38
capabilities attached and perhaps caps
this time for example to take out of the
example I just gave and you attach that
to the binary instead and then when a
user executes that binary the process
gets just that capability and if the
program could somehow be compromised
then the attacker can do less damage
hopefully because the program is a less
powerful program than a set UID root
program so just so that the the what I
want you to take away from this is the
idea you know that processes can have
capabilities some subset of the power of
root capabilities can be attached to
executable files and when when users
execute those files the resulting
process has whatever capability was
attached to the file and that having
these processes that have a subset of
the power of super user in other words
just one or two cables and having
binaries that have just one of the
capabilities instead of being set UID
route binaries this the idea is here we
can create a
less dangerous world in a corner
security sense okay so this is this is
one of the pieces I'm gonna really just
skip I mentioned already this idea that
namespaces provide isolation I just want
to say that we do have a bunch of
different namespace types as what I said
in the previous session there are seven
different namespace types at the moment
soon there's going to be one or two more
one of them is actually going the new
the next namespace that's likely to
appear by the one way is time namespaces
so you know processes that are in
different time namespace instances they
see different time so we've got seven
different types of namespaces and the
one that I haven't really talked about
yet which is were now talking about now
is user name spaces so skip skip skip
skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip
skip skip skip skip skip skip user name
spaces now what user name spaces do is
allow us to have UID oh sorry per
namespace UID and GID Maps the idea here
is you know process that's inside user
name space it has a certain user ID in a
certain group ID and outside the user
name space it has a different user ID
and a different group ID and the
interesting use case here is the process
that since IDs namespace it has UID 0 it
is super user it has all the powers of
super user but outside the namespace
it's it's some unpublished user ID it
doesn't have any of the powers of super
user outside that user name space user
name spaces are like PID no spaces which
I talked about a little bit in the last
session they have a hierarchical
relationship we've got the notion that a
you each user name space has a parent
user name space which has a parent user
name space going back to the initial
user name space
the way that this parental relationship
gets established as when a news
namespace is created
that's done by calling a clone or
unshared system call the process that
creates the new user namespace the
parent of that user namespace is the
username space of the process that
called clone or unshare to create the
news namespace that's that's how this
this hierarchical raishin chip gets
built up and one of the reasons that
this parental relationship matters is
because it determines that rules about
how capabilities work and because we
have a little bit more time than a
normally have I might even have time to
talk about those rules we'll just see
okay so there's just a an example
picture of a user name space hierarchy
where some user name spaces are children
of other user name spaces now when a
when a news namespace is created the
very first process inside that username
space by definition the kernel just does
this automatically that new process has
a full set of capabilities so we made
the clone system called the client
system called created the child process
in a new user name space and the
currently says automatically that
process has all capabilities all the
powers of super user but only inside the
user namespace and unpacking what that
means is it's the whole point of why I'm
here right now okay
so one of the things that we need to do
with user namespaces when we create a
news namespace if we we need to find UID
and GID Maps these maps are saying the
cradles inside the namespace what do
they correspond to outside the namespace
in the parent user namespace so one of
the very first things that you do after
creating a new user namespace is you
define what these mappings are going to
look like and the way that you do this
is by writing suitable strings to two
files for the process that's inside the
namespace in the proc
kid UID map file in the proper GID map
file to begin with the content of these
two files is empty but for the processes
inside the new user namespace you then
write strings to these two files and
that defines what the mappings are going
to look like a view IDs and group IDs so
there's a whole lot of rules about doing
this because this is all very security
sensitive stuff so you can't just do
arbitrary things in terms of creating
these mappings there's a whole bunch of
rules I can't I just don't have time to
talk about the rules here but you can
read about them in the in the user
namespaces manual page but essentially
what you're doing is writing to these
files strings that look like this lines
that look like this some ID inside the
namespace maps to a different ID outside
of the namespace and then a range so for
example you might have a map that looks
like this where it says zero inside the
namespace maps to 1000 outside the
namespaces in the parent namespace for a
range of one only one user ID is valid
inside this namespace well you could
have said here ten and that will be
saying 0 through to nine inside the
namespace maps to 1000 through to one
thousand and nine outside the namespace
okay this this namespace by though I
misspoke this this kind of mapping by
the way we're just a single you ideas
map and it's the UID 0 inside the
namespaces something outside the
namespace is called the route mapping
now using the unshare command which i
mentioned earlier on we can create a new
user name space with the dash capital u
option and if we say - R as well this is
all look automated is create for me
route mappings for the UID map and the
GID map so we could do something like
this
I'm very put off by the interlacing here
can you see this down the back ok this
yeah ok maybe it looks worse for me than
that that's for you actually
so here for example I start off as an
unprivileged user UID 1000 GID 1000 and
then I say create a new user name space
unshare - you with - are the root
mappings I run a bash shell in that news
namespace and then I turn around and
what unshare is done beside behind the
scenes for me is write some strings to
the UID map and the GID map and then I
can just check what those mappings that
I'm sure is created for me what what
they look like so I can't proc dollar
dollar UID map I see
0 maps to 1000 for one inside the night
for range of 1 and 0 for the GID map 0
inside the user name space maps to 1000
outside again for a range of 1 and if I
look so it's so I've changed the shell
prompt here by the way just doing the
Cape that you know this is a different
shell and you in a news namespace if I
from that shell look at the credentials
of the shell process
I see that has UID 0 and GID 0 and this
is one of the points about user
namespaces that whenever you look at
credentials in any context the
credentials are always mapped according
was showing you according to whatever
the UID map and the GID map that are
defined for your user name space define
those user IDs should be so even though
outside the in the outside world this
process has UID 1000 from our
perspective inside these namespace
looks like we have UID 0 and when I look
in the proc page status file to find out
about the processes credentials and
capabilities again I say UID 0 g ID 0
and for the effective capabilities i see
that this process has all capabilities
there are 9 FS there that's nine nine
times four bits is 36 and three is two
more bits that's 38 bits that are on
okay those 38 capabilities of course
none of us is very good at interpreting
hex strings there is a program called
get get peek apps that you can use to
actually display these capability sets
in a human I like to call it a human
readable if not necessarily human
comprehensible formats because the
notation is not that easy to understand
but at least it's a bit more readable
than hexadecimal okay now from our new
shell we check what the PID is it's a
certain number and then from a shell in
the initial username space I then turn
around and say well let's go look at the
credentials of that process in proc Pig
status and seen from the shell in the
initial username space the process looks
like it has credentials you know UID
1000 PID 1000 okay because here from a
shell in the initial username space we
see the credentials as they would appear
in that username space okay now we might
then say well hey in that news announcer
and that unit in the in space we have
all capabilities Wow perhaps I can start
doing interesting stuff
perhaps I can change the host name for
example so then I try to do that say
host name changed the host name of the
system and I get straightaway an error
message to change the host name requires
the cap source admin capability and this
process has the caps as admin capability
nevertheless it can't change the host
name and we'll see why soon okay the key
point is that the new shell there by the
way is still in the initial UTS
namespace now let's talk about user
namespaces and capabilities so the first
process and the news namespace gets a
full set of capabilities but those
capabilities can only be exercised on
objects that are governed by
the new username space question
processor what does that mean we know
some things already there's a bunch of
different namespace types currently
seven each one of those namespace types
governs some sort of global resource UTS
namespaces they govern host name and
domain name mount namespaces they govern
the list of mount points Network
namespaces govern a bunch of network
related resources now what I want to add
to this mixed is mixes that each
non-user namespace is owned by some
particular user namespace there's always
an ownership relationship every non user
name space belongs to some particular
user namespace and when we create a new
non user namespace same time we do that
what happens is that the new non user
namespace automatically is owned by the
user namespace in which the creating
process resides and that's how the
ownership relationship gets established
now if a process operates on resources
that are governed by some norm use
namespace what the kernel checks is what
are the processes capabilities in the
user name space that owns the non user
namespace that governs the resources
okay so that was very abstract let's try
and make this more concrete by a picture
and the picture I'm going to show you is
the picture that would result when we
executed this command unshare - capital
you created username space with the
route mappings just because that's
simple - lower case you create a new UTS
namespace at the same time and run some
program now here's what we get as a
result first of all this is the program
in the that was run that was run here
okay now this program this process
running this program
it's in a new user name space is the
initial user name space that was created
when the system was booted up well we've
just created the new user name space and
because we created the new UTS namespace
at the same time there's a new UTS
namespace here and because what's
created at the same time as the user
name space it's owned by the initial but
by the new user namespace
okay now this process here
it has effective user IDs zero inside
the namespace but outside the namespace
as effective user ID 1000 something this
is as unprivileged user ad 1000 it has a
full set of capabilities that's what
this notation here means equals EP all
capabilities ineffective and permitted
it's in a new user name space it's in a
new UTS namespace but for example it is
still a member of the initial network
namespace and the reason is that when we
created this process we created the new
UTS namespace on the new user name space
but we can create a new network
namespace so this new this new process
is in the same network namespace as its
parent was and it's also in the same
it's just it's also in the initial PID
namespace the initial C group namespace
the initial mal namespace there's no IP
seen in space and so on it just haven't
didn't have room to show all those other
namespaces and of course there's an
initial UTS namespace as well but this
process is a member of the second UTS
namespace now suppose this process is I
want to change the host name and change
those name need to have the caps Asst
admin capability so this process or the
the kernel first of all says you know if
a process wants to change the host name
host names are governed by the UTS
namespace so the colonel's first
question is you know which UTS namespace
does this process reside in and the
answer is this one and then the colonel
says well which use the namespace owns
this username the UTS namespace and the
answer is this one and then the
colonel's question is
what Pro what capabilities does this
process have in that year's namespace
and the answer is it has all
capabilities and it's a member of the
namespace so it has all capabilities in
that user namespace and therefore this
process will be allowed to change the
host name on the other hand suppose this
process tried to bind a privileged
Network port something less than 1024
this requires a certain cable it's
called cap net bind service now the
kernel says we wanted to publish Network
operation which network namespace does
this process reside it the answer is
this one and then the kernels next
question is which user namespace owns
that that network namespace and the
answer is the swamp then the kernels
question is what capabilities does this
process have in that user namespace and
the answer is it has all capabilities
but it's not in that user namespace so
it has no capabilities there and
therefore it can't bind the privilege
network port I really like this picture
now there are some api's and I don't
wanna try and go into details but there
are some api's you can use to discover
this the hierarchical relationship
between username spaces and the
ownership relationship between non user
and user name spaces I'm not gonna try
and go into this I will just mention at
the in the inside you'll see a pointer
to a location of some code and do have a
go program that makes use of these api's
to draw you a picture of the namespaces
on your system but I've been using C for
30 years it still hurts
dough is so easy okay so let's let's
let's just try some demonstrations with
that program so I think I'll do that
down here so I'm going to do exactly
what I just showed you which is to say
unshare - new - new user name space with
root mappings creating UTS namespace at
the same time and then I'll just run a
bash shell now just to demonstrate some
things here the shell up above is in the
initial instance of all the various
namespaces and I can say read link /proc
proc slash dollar dollar / NS / user for
example I see a certain magic number
there down here I can do a similar
command read link /proc / dollar dollar
/ NS / user I see a different number
this information is telling me these two
processes are in different username
spaces if I do the same thing for the
UTS symlink
again different numbers these two proces
are in different UTS namespaces but if
for example I do the same thing for the
network some link same number these two
prices are in the same network namespace
are in the same C group namespace the
same IP c namespace okay because when we
created that that shell in the bottom
window all we said at that moment was
create a new user name space and a new
UTS namespace and the new shell is still
a member of all the other at the initial
instance of all the other namespaces so
just to to illustrate what things are
looking like on the system then and just
to give you a display that kind of
relates back to that picture I just
showed you here I've got a shell that
the shell on the lower window there okay
PID one five nine four eight and up here
I've got a another shell with a
different PID one five one six one what
I'm going to do now is just make use of
that go program that I've just talked to
you about and I will say sudo go run
namespaces off block go now potentially
this program by default it will show me
information about all the namespaces on
the system and all the processes on the
system that's that's too much
information but what I want to say is
let's see the information about the
namespaces of PID one five one six one
and one five nine four eight and even
that's too much information for me
because I don't want to see information
about all the namespaces I want to
restrict the set of namespaces just so I
don't get so much output so I'm going to
say gee I wrote this program
[Laughter]
I hope I got it right there
UTS comma knit
okay I didn't get it right it's this
let's try that again
what have I done wrong
huh
one moment maybe maybe it's just this
yeah there was it namespaces okay
now this picture then is is is is
straight in the pointy remember we had
two shells the shell down here with PID
one five nine four eight the other shell
which had PID one five one six one and
what we're seeing here is a picture of
the namespaces and their relationships
at least for the username space the
network name spaces and the UTS name
spaces and so we see here first of all
there is a username space at the top
that is the initial username space it's
owned by user ID zero there's an API
that you can use to discover who owns a
particular username space and the name
space has a certain magic inode number
that's unique for this namespace there's
a child username space you can tell us
char because the indentation that's mine
that's mine current notation it's it was
created by user ID 1000 it's got a
different of course I know it number and
owned by that new user namespace there's
a UTS namespace you can tell its own
because indentation and of course
there's an initial network namespace
it's owned by the install user name
space an initial UTS namespace that's
owned by the initial user namespace and
then let's look at the namespace
memberships of the of the various
process and the way I discovered this by
the way in my go program is I just went
through and passed all the proc perd any
assim links on the system and matched up
the numbers okay so there's a lot of
file system the pseudo file system
activity that we know on behind the
scenes so the process down here one five
nine four eight it's in the new it's in
the new user namespace it's in the new
UTS namespace but it's still a member of
the initial network namespace okay
whereas the shell in the top window it's
a member of the initial instance of all
of the various namespaces the initial
network namespace the initial UTS
namespace the initial user namespace
make sense oh I'm doing good for time
this is so relaxed okay so what sort of
stuff excuse me what sort of stuff can
you do with username spaces
I'll make sure that I'm on the downward
slope now you can run your Linux
containers without root privileges so
docker has modes for doing this Alex C
has modes for doing this
nowadays some things that people used to
do with set UID route helpers like
sandboxing the rendering process and
browsers to set up the rendering
environment for the for the for the
sorry the yeah the the sandbox
environment for the rendering process
used to be that browsers like chrome
would use a set UID root process to set
up the sandbox which can set you ID root
program yeah dangerous let's avoid them
nowadays you can do the necessary
sandbox instead by using user name
spaces along with some other namespaces
and so you review you've removed one
dangerous program from the system this
is interesting you can set up a user
name space where the UID map looks like
this 1000 1001 you know some unpublished
ID maps to the same ID in the parent
namespace for range of one there is no
concept of super user inside this user
namespace you can't have privileged
processes inside this namespace from a
security perspective that's a nice
guarantee to have you know that there
can't be dangerous processes in that
space you can do what people used to do
with chroot for i setting process and
file systems but using user name spaces
and
mountain spaces you can do so much more
in terms of completely rearranging the
file system set up that a group of
processes sees thank root I don't know
who's who's heard a fake root just by
the way if you use Debian you probably
have heard of fake root fake roots a
package that's a shared library that is
used in conjunction it's a pre-loaded
shared library it's used in conjunction
with the Debian package creator program
and the Debian package kradic program is
going to create a package with some
metadata saying you know who should own
these files when these files are
installed on the target system and the
package creative program just says well
I'm gonna put whatever a UID and GID I
am being run with into the metadata so
it just calls get UID and or get a UID
to find out what its what effective user
ID it's being run with so if you wanted
to create a package where the files
should be owned by UID 0 on the target
system one possibility would be that you
[Music]
run excuse me that you would run the
package creation program a superuser
yeah yes every time you something a
super user this is always a little risk
of something will go wrong
so thank root what it does is it it's a
pre-loaded shared library that provides
wrappers around the get UID and get GID
system calls and all the raid system
tools and the rap functions don't even
call the system calls they just lie so
that when when the package Menace is you
know get UID the hreflang just come
access JIRA page page creation purchases
okay alright to zero in to the metadata
now you know you instead of missing room
with with a pre-loaded shared library
you make life even simpler you can ever
I use a name space where there's a the
root mapping no need for shared
libraries anymore ok then a couple of
other tools ok
one of the reasons or one of the reasons
that all these namespaces were suddenly
invented was to do the container thing
but people have come up with some really
interesting other uses as well and
a couple of other cases that I find
really interesting a fire jail and
flat-pack and I'm just curious by the
way who's heard of fire jail not so many
people flat-pack usually a few more
people okay so fire jail is a sort of
generalized sandboxing tool so that you
can run some application in some sort of
sandbox where if it gets compromised or
is malicious somehow it's limited in the
damage that it can do and the same
boxing is done using namespaces also
using C groups which I haven't talked
about the wall of course using another
feature of the kernel called set comp
which limits system calls that can be
made I talked here last year about set
comp maybe you wanted to view are there
I don't know and you can just set up a
set of sandboxing rules describing what
kind of sandbox you want and put it into
a so-called profile and then run your
application under the control of that
profile using a fire jail and it's it's
got some degree of sandboxing around it
so that if it gets compromised you know
it can do less damage that would be
interesting in itself but what makes
fire jail really interesting is it comes
with a bunch of prepackaged profiles so
you get when you install fire jail you
get a profile for Thunderbird a profile
for Firefox a profile I don't know I
think for LibreOffice a I don't know I
can check that one but a profiles
prepackaged for a bunch of commonly used
applications that you can use right out
of the box so then you can run all of
your favorite applications inside a
sandbox so they are more restricted in
what they can do in case they should
somehow be compromised it's interesting
stuff flat pack is again it's it's using
namespaces that also set comp and and C
groups and capabilities to solve the
package management problem in a
different way the the idea here is or
rephrase this
does anybody here use Debian Debian's
Debian stable anyone
the great thing about Debian staple is
it stable the terrible thing about
Debian stable is it as stable what I
mean by this is and every distribution
has this problem it's just somewhat more
extreme with Debian which is you know
you you you you want the some cool new
software project out there and you want
to use it but it hasn't been packaged
for your distribution is this is most
extreme and Debian stable because the
release cycles are so long but every
distribution to some extend or other has
this problem and what do you do at that
point you want to use the cool new
software there's no package for it for
your system so maybe download the
tarball build and and you know just
build from tar ball and install manually
but maybe the application has some
dependencies on another package you need
to manually set up those other packages
to get the dependencies right
maybe you mess up along the way and you
bust your package management database
and you feel sad for a day or two you
know you can do it there's a little risk
it's inconvenient and as a little risk
you might get wrong and you you create
some unnecessary work for yourself let's
put things other way around you are the
creator of the cool new package those
cool new software I should say and you
want your downstream users to use it but
those lazy downstream distribution
maintainer z' haven't packaged your
software yet haven't they got something
they have so much else to do why do they
do it so what do you do you could say to
your users I'm sorry against a build
from source man it's not so nice but you
know and that's possibility or you could
go into the package maintenance business
you could say oh okay I'll create a I'll
create a fedora package for fedora
fedora or a xxx package for my software
no I better I better create a new bundle
package as well some people are still
using 32-bit systems I'll need a fedora
32-bit package oh and fedora change in a
way that is incompatible for me with
Fedora 23 only it's creative Fedora 23
package you can see this gets old really
quickly you don't do it unless you've
got a lot of resources of other words
you're a big company
so not very nice flat pack
what flat pack does is as the upstream
bill if you install flat pack on your
system and then you create a flat pack
of your of your of your project of your
binary and I should have mentioned by
the way flat pack is an implementation
of an idea that was initially proposed
by Linnet / Turing the creator of system
D and the idea is that the flat pack
that gets created it has the binary that
the upstream developers created and all
of its dependencies all the shared
libraries that needs flat pack just
assembles everything that's necessary
and puts it into the flat pack package
and then you could say that your
downstream users you want to use my
software just just down and store that
pack on your system download the flat
pack and then run the flat pack and just
out of the box it works automatically on
in distribution because the flat pack
contains all of the necessary
dependencies of the binary and this is
all being done with namespaces SATCOM
capabilities to provide not only the
application packaging but also some
sandboxing along the way as well and
sometimes people pop up at this point
and say well there but docker couldn't I
just done this with docker no because
doing the GUI thing with docker it
doesn't really work very well generally
thing is with flat pack you can have a
GUI application you get a Firefox or
LibreOffice in a flat pack and you you
you you run the flat pack on the target
system and the GUI application just
integrates seamlessly into the desktop
environment so this is there's a lot of
magical things that are people are doing
with namespaces and some of these other
technologies as well but that were
originally invented for containers but
are now being used in some really
interesting creative other ways ok in
terms of other information we want to
find more about namespaces I wrote a
series of articles on llw in a few years
ago but some manual pages I wrote
oh and I mentioned in the previous
session as well this this this is this
is a great great web page written by a
woman in California or about you know
how to do how to do the container thing
in C and you don't need much code to do
it the reason that contains systems are
so complicated there's all the
infrastructure that goes into the
orchestration I don't know I've got some
backup slides but I don't know whether
oh yeah just one one thing you know I
think this is worth talking about as
long as we hear when does a process have
capabilities inside a namespace I taught
I showed you that picture already but
there's a bit more to it than this what
are the rules that determine whether a
process has capabilities in a particular
user namespace so you'll see in the
manual pages you know you can do
such-and-such such thing if you have
capabilities in that user name space the
relevant user name space somehow and the
question is what are the rules that
determine whether a process has cape
lutes and name space so we know already
user name spaces exist in a hierarchy
each user name space has a parent going
back to the initial user name space
which obviously has no parent the
parental relationship gets established
when the user name space is created the
parental relationship matters because
it's significant in imp as part of the
answer to this question when does the
process have capabilities in a user name
space there's a whole lot of factors
that come into play does a process have
capability news announcements well the
first thing is does the process even
have the capability that's part of the
answer to the question obviously it
depends on which Capon which user name
space the process is a member of it
depends on the processes effective user
ID depends on the effective user ID of
the process that created the user names
the target user name space the one that
we're asking about so we've got a
process that perhaps is living in one
user name space but it wants to do
something in another user name space
that's the target user name space the
question is who created that target user
name space and then at the the what else
matters is the parental relationship
between these two namespaces
now there is a program I got in the
source code that on my website that
encapsulates the rules that I'm about to
show you next
basically it's you can give it two
arguments a PID and a proc pettiness
user sim link and then will tell you it
does that process have capabilities in
that namespace okay so the rules go like
this a process has a capability or news
namespace if it's a member of the user
namespace and it has the capability
that's pretty much tautological this
rule doesn't give the process any
capabilities in the parent namespace
only in the namespace where it resides a
process that has a capability in a user
name space automatically has that
capability in all descendant user name
spaces as well so in other words if
you're super user at one level in the
user name space hierarchy your super
user every place lower down as well or
to put things another way you know you
can't as someone else hide from the
power of super user inside user name
space by running away into some inferior
user names best doesn't work because
super user at some level has a super
user one use one level hierarchy has
super user powers all the way down and
then one more rule and this this is an
interesting one
any process that's in a parent username
space that has a user ID that matches
the user ID that was used to create a
child username space that process
automatic as all capabilities in the
child username space so in other words
you know as an unprivileged user I might
have created the I'm pervious user ID
1000 I might have created the child
username space there are some prices
inside that user name space and maybe
I'm running a shell in the parent
username space and I'm running this gel
is user ID 1000 that shell has
capabilities over all of the processes
that are in the child username space
because the shell has effective user ad
1000 which is the same as the effective
user ID that was used to create the
child username space and that means the
other there might be processes inside
that charges in a space with different
credentials between
actually but I could still send signals
to them I could still kill them for
example because the the shell and the
Pyrenean space has a user ID that
matches the user ID of the child
username space that that probe that user
81,000 is God from outside the user
namespace okay I think that's enough but
I'm three questions yes do you mean the
the example I showed on the shell
session or what do you mean the picture
oh you got a good memory
I'm impressed 545 this one yes that's
right so the host name would be visible
to this process but if there were
processes you know and that lives in
this UTS namespace that host name you
know it's not visible to the processes
that live in this UTS namespace and and
then this is this is the whole point
that you know you you're creating a sort
of a new isolated world that's governed
by a new user name space that owns some
non-news namespaces that govern some
resources and you can mess around with
those resources but you can't mess
around with the resources in the initial
you name space instances and then this
is this is why you can be super user
inside the news namespace but only you
only have super user powers on sort of
the the resources that live in that new
isolated container that you've created
said a question
okay so that's that's that's a that's a
good other question that I think I did
have in a backup slave revive zip past
it already but I'll come back to it
there are some resources on the system
that aren't governed by namespaces
things like time it's not currently
probably very soon they will be by
governed by a new name space but
currently they're not and what that
means is for these resort and another
example is it's a loading kernel modules
okay you know the the the new process in
the news namespace it gets the
capability caps this module cannot load
kernel modules yeah we hope not well the
thing is for these sort of resources
that aren't governed by namespaces what
the kernel then asks is what capably
does that process have in the initial
user namespace so game over you know you
can't do anything special you can't
change the system time for example for
now for now but in the next few months
that is very likely to change other
questions I've heard there's a good
party to go to
it was good last year let and they do
good good food good parties here oh
there is a question we are I'm leaving
[Laughter]
yeah I think it well you know and what I
said what I'm I'll back up sticking the
there was a sort of milestone release
back in 2013 this was Linux 3.8 and what
happened then that milestone Reece was
they finally said we think we've got to
sort of some sort of stage of maturity
now where we're going to let now
unprivileged users create user name
spaces before that you could create user
name spaces but you had to have caps us
admin cable you had to be super user but
they the goal they were working towards
was allowing this to be possible for
onion privileged users to do safely and
they reached they consider themselves to
have reached that goal in 2013 and that
point they said okay you don't need caps
anymore to create a user name space and
preceding that that been about six years
of work part of it was because it was
young complicated but the other part is
people were super nervous like you know
we're talking about giving a process
Super User powers and you know we want
to be really sure that those Super User
powers couldn't somehow be leaking out
and letting letting the process do
something I'm privileged in another
username space where it shouldn't be
possible in particular in the initial
user name space you know that'll be
really bad it turns out there have been
a few vulnerabilities like that that
have been discovered after the fact
because there were some obscure corner
cases that people didn't think you know
as yeah software has bugs who knew and
those bugs have been found and fixed and
I haven't heard there's been a few of
them I haven't heard of so many in the
last few years so maybe just maybe that
all those bugs have been shaken out now
yeah I don't know if I answered your
question or not do I think it's
inevitable they could have figured out
they could do what I'm sorry I don't
everything's gonna be none earlier with
efficient resources and it's not like
the whole concept of virtualization at
some level there's quite an old concept
you know famously that I forget the
details there was virtualization going
on when some subsystems with with
system/360 in the 1960s you know not not
this kind of virtualization but you know
virtualization kind of techniques being
used and Solaris for instance
independently had something called zones
which is a rather similar concept so I
don't
to begin with we had hypervisors then
someone did the isolation of mountain
namespaces and then people suddenly rose
come we start doing all the sort of
virtualization that we were doing with
hypervisors but in the context of a
single kernel and then now where we have
to isolate to do that and then they
could clear okay and network resources
will be useful you IPC resources will be
useful a bunch of other things you the
hostname be useful and then they started
work on these pieces independently and
the fact that they worked on them
independently actually and that you know
sometimes people ask me you know why is
it so complicated why isn't it just an
API button that I can press it says give
me a new container that would be make
life simple in some ways but the it
would have made life more difficult in
other ways like by implementing the
different pieces separately it means
that the implementation could be done
piecewise so it made the implementation
effort easier but now the fact they were
all implemented as separate pieces that
can be used independently means they can
be used together independently in
different ways so we can do the
flat-pack thing with a fire jail thing
so it's actually I think an extremely
good thing that there wasn't just an API
button that says give me a container
that wouldn't have been nearly so
interesting as it's the world we now
have but you know could it have been
done earlier I don't know it's it's a
question about the past I'm not much
better at the past the neighbors at the
future
enjoy your evening thank you
[Applause]